it wasn't about the fashion it was about
the women that's what a supermodel is
[Music]
the first time we're all together in our
50s
you see our photo so you feel that you
know us
when you come together with your chosen
family I think that's emotional
there's something about that shared
history that we have
I feel blessed that we're here today
we've all gone through so many things in
our own lives
Cindy Linda Christian Naomi I still
redefine in what it means to be a model
there was a feeling about them that they
wanted more I was not seen as a person
who had a voice in her own destiny he
said you should lose five pounds I got
scared I didn't for long but Linda's a
chameleon she could really become
whatever the photographer wanted her to
become I would do all these great shows
where were these beautiful dresses but
then it would come times the advertising
and I would not be included I wasn't
going to be bullied for the color of my
skin what I loved about the girls they
were a group and that was so fabulous we
were always together and we made great
photos together you know I just felt
like to be together as a group it just
was so fun they were my sisters you get
this phone call but George Michael wants
to shoot us in his video we made a
decision I will do it I'm gonna do it
yes okay I'll do it
everything changed you can start to call
the shots and be an active participant
in your career all of a sudden you were
the physical representations of power I
wanted to go further I wanted to push
the envelope
they brought their Artistry to the image
they would see things we didn't
necessarily see they liked the Mona Lisa
the face of her era they're Larger than
Life
we helped break down barriers I have to
think of something greater than myself
when I first was referred to as a
supermodel I was like why they quoted us
this it wasn't about the hair and the
makeup it wasn't about the fashion it
was about the women
that's what a supermodel is
[Music]